a chest of his special European Council
in Brussels I reached a deal with the
leaders of the other 27 EU Member States
on a withdrawal agreement that will
ensure our smooth and orderly departure
on the 29th of March next year we can
back this deal deliver on the vote of
the referendum and move on to building a
brighter future of opportunity and
prosperity for all our people or this
house can choose to reject this deal and
go back to square one because no one
knows what would happen if this deal
doesn't pass it would open the door to
more division and more uncertainty with
all the risks that will entail
I joined me here at the big table is
John Werth he's one of the most watched
bricks at bloggers and analysts here on
the continent John it's good to see you
again when I listen to the British Prime
Minister there I get the impression that
it's either her brexit plan or the end
of empire 2.0 I mean it's like an
apocalypse but it's in her interest to
present it as such a such a poppet
apocalyptic terms she wants to up the
pressure on her conservative members of
parliament to get them to back her deal
she wants to talk tough they believe do
they believe her not today it didn't
sound like they were believing her today
the parliamentary of the rithmetic is
very strongly against to resume managing
to get this deal through on the 11th of
December and so she's gonna have to
control them bully them pressure them
and try and hope that somehow or other
she can cobble together a majority but
the the arithmetic looks very bad for
Teresa major I know labor opposition
leader Jeremy Corbyn today asked simply
why can't there be a plan B
take a listen mr. speaker ploughing on
is not stoical it's an act of national
self-harm
instead of threatening this house with a
No Deal scenario or a no brexit scenario
the Planck Prime Minister now needs to
repair a plan B something her
predecessors failed to do I mean why
can't there be a plan B the time tip for
brakes it is now very very tight Theresa
May has used up almost all of the two
years foreseen for brexit and we're now
just sixteen weeks ahead of brexit we
finally got it Jeremy Corbyn knew that
you know 18 months ago that the clock
was ticking right yeah but he has no
plan B either which is the whole
contradiction here so essentially there
were a series of different breakfasts
which were essentially available to the
UK but ultimately Theresa May has
piloted towards this variant she wants
to control immigration into the UK above
all else and that is why Britain has
ended up with this brexit deal now it's
a bit contradictory from Jeremy Corbyn
to say we need a plan B because he
doesn't have that plan B either now on
also very my the EU doesn't really want
a plan B
themselves either but because of the
short time frame that that is imposed on
therefore I talked about that in just a
second I mean that the achievement
though of getting 27 countries to all
give their blessing to your breaks at
plan I mean Theresa May she deserves
some praise there does she deserve some
praise the EU deserve some praise the e
u--'s negotiated this extremely well but
bear in mind that that is very much
though that this plan which is on the
table is bears all of the hallmarks of a
plan made for and negotiated for Theresa
May and the problem is is the
pragmatists in her Conservative Party
don't like it the bricks at hardliners
in her party don't like it the Northern
Irish DUP don't like it
so it's attacked from all sides but he
hates it then it has to be a Chancellor
she she likes it somewhat take a listen
to what she had to say yesterday
diplomatic work of art has been
accomplished in an extremely difficult
situation an unprecedented situation
something we have never had to face
until now a country leaving the European
Union having to create a contractual
exit agreement taking in
to account the different interests but
also at the same time looking towards
the future I mean a diplomatic work of
art I mean with the Mongol America
that's about as high as it gets but
there's just one thing that I'm thinking
though the UK it maybe not getting
everything it wants but isn't the EU
getting everything he was getting pretty
much everything and of course America
would say this is brilliant this is an
excellent deal as far as the EU is
concerned the EU has achieved all of its
aims it's making sure there's no hard
border in Ireland it's got its financial
settlement for the contributions to the
EU budget citizens rights could have
done a little bit more but a generally
generally sorted and the integrity of
the EU single market is assured this is
an excellent deal as far as the European
Union side is concerned okay so what
happens between now and December 11th
there's going to be a lot of noise and
not very much light probably from from
the UK side essentially Theresa May is
trying to find a way means of getting
some kind of majority of her breaks a
deal she's going to try to get as many
conservative politicians to back her as
possible but it looks extremely unlikely
there are more than 90 conservative
members apartment we've already said
that they're opposed to such a deal so
the ultimate thing is going to be
basically that deal everyone is counting
on the deal being voted down on it so
that persons who are closer to the heart
breaks it a new deal breaks it even
obrecht's have without any deal now the
opposition Labour Party they've said
hold on a minute that's not necessary
you could extend the negotiation period
something which Brussels also doesn't
want
so essentially Britain is in a period of
kind of the calm before the storm just
now on the 11th of December or shortly
afterwards all kinds of hell will break
loose
to resume could be ousted there could be
calls for a second referendum um to
rerun that referendum about Britain's EU
membership so when it's calm just now
but two weeks from now and there's going
to be a major crisis on our I'm sure
we'll be talking about here on this show
just before that he'll break self as
you've predicted there John worth is
always good to have you on the show
thanks for your insights thank you
you
[Music]